let's talk about something nice to end
this year off before we call it today
swag money what's what's the what's
what's the best thing that happened to
you guys this year let's let's have some
positivity to end things off
[Laughter]
hemorrhoids you're going to get a
hemorrhoid you got to get the
hemorrhoids man this is going to be an
arc cont trash taste has G got
hemorrhoids the hemorrhoids are I still
I still do not have hemorrhoids hemid
Jack it's kind of H can gig beat beat H
it's a coffee coughing baby versus
hydrogen bomb hemorrhoids versus
gig which one's which we'll never
tell uh what is the best thing that
happened this year this year's kind of
been a blur I don't know about done so
much right so it's like kind of hard to
I will say I mean you had your tie W
yeah oh yeah that was this year that was
January holy [__] okay you guys got to
experience my home country yeah we saw
[__] that was so much fun I'm still
salty about the partai that you paid for
I'm salty after about it it wasn't
wasn't bad though I definitely could
have had better though you guys came to
Australia as well right yeah I [__]
love Australia yeah um and we and we
went to Wales for the Europe tour so we
all visited each other's home countries
this year well we we went to Cardiff
Cardiff it's not really Wales it's I
mean you guys went to Melbourne it's you
know my favorite um my favorite memory
from Cardiff is when we went to the
castle Yeah and we met that Welsh guy
who seemed oddly proud of how many times
all the dud standing in the in front of
the castle this this this talk I was
like oddly proud of how many times this
Castle had been taken over and stormed
and and he's like it's still standing
there yeah it's that Wales is just that
Goku meme where he's on fire and smiling
like that is Wales cuz like hey we we
always get [__] but we never
leave I think you know around them at
that period there was a lot of countries
that got taken over especially in Europe
right and whales the one that was like
no we lose but we're staying and they
just kept getting [__] from Millennia
and they were like we're still here what
do you
want damn it was pretty funny just how
excited he was cuz like he found out we
were doing the show in ciff and he was
like oh next time you should do a show
in the castle and I'm like what it could
fit like 60 people in there like be
great it would be fun to do a show in a
castle um or just anything in the castle
castle is just cool let's [__] in the
castle uh I don't know what else I mean
we did so much traveling this year and a
lot of new countries as well which was
always hype know I just had a lot of fun
you know doing all the cool streaming
stuff this year probably was highlight
for me doing all that fun crazy projects
that I've been working on the year
before yeah charity auction Charity
Auction was a huge hype for me that was
amazing yeah that was really I genuinely
like it's been such a blurry year that I
was like was that yester year or was
that last year this year June we're
getting to that point no I I swear to
God sometime I don't know if years are
just getting longer for everyone or if
just 3 months feels like get
shorter they're getting shorter right
cuz 2023 felt like it went by like like
that for me but also 3 months ago feels
like a year ago for me almost that's
because we're doing a bunch of [__] G 3
months ago we were like on tour yeah not
even two months
ago it was October bro [__] no sorry no
you're right it was no it was 3 months
it was 3 months it was three months yeah
that felt like a year ago man I just I
mean the US tour was a year ago yeah
that's true which feels like 5 years
that feels like 5 years ago I don't know
our year is getting longer or shorter I
don't know but this year felt it kind of
felt like a blur but it also
felt I don't there was no good games
this
year no good anime
either there there's no good anime no
good games it was all of blood no no
games this year there was just no games
just none IED your
thought trying to think well maybe
Connor if you played Boulders Gate 3 and
not the [__] sua game game of the
year you'd uh you'd think that uh they
were good games I mean there were good
games this year cuz uh honai
star it was a weird year it felt like a
year of continuation I think that was
the theme of this year yeah in many
senses it just felt like an extension to
the years prior of almost like
recovering from Co yeah in a way it was
kind of just like people weren't really
figuring out exactly how to get back
into the swing of things because we had
just come out of the whole Co thing that
was last year though no but like it kind
of ended early I feel like it's still
going I feel like people are still
mentally readjusting from that whole
period people are like oh man it's we
were locked up for so long how do we
like life again well you know what the
Ki of the year was for Japan every year
they have a kanji that symbolizes the
year what was it it was tax this year uh
for all the tax hikes this year so tax
was the CI of the year I'm not kidding
tax was the Ki of the
year what the because Japanese people
obvious like [__] raising the
tax on us this year yeah um is that
serious yeah look it up last year last
year you know what it was what
war no it was fight it was war the year
before correct uh was it War the year
before MIT oh no so 2020 was mits which
means uh to stay close because Co right
2021 was king or gold because of the
Olympics oh uh yeah 2022 was EXA which
means war my fight two and 2023 was
there which is
tax evil is there a reason why I believe
it's because of the tax hikes they were
a huge part of Japanese uh kind of meme
culture as well well it's also probably
because during like Japan just got
completely [__]
up of them writing this country it's
really like it's very fun to watch it's
like a very very yeah guy stands on the
podium and he's like the Year this
year's kanji is it's so intense this guy
just kind of like this really old man
with this giant brush writes this
beautiful Kani so Japan chooses taxes
Kani the year amid concern over cost of
living uh has been chosen as Japan's
word of the year in a reflection of
growing public anxiety over the cost of
living and impeding tax raises I feel
like they've blown the low too early CU
I think it's only going to get worse
four years in a row tax four years in a
row
that's what that's what it was in the
housing housing is next year housing is
next year economy the year after that do
you think during the great sagge it was
just tax tax tax tax there no money to
tax well at least uh Taylor Swift was a
person of the year right yeah next year
will be
Swift like hay did you did you did you
hear about her interview that she gave
after winning person of the year no uh
did she say I was born in
what do this me and it walked off what
is this meme there's this there's this
meme of all of her concerts where like
she starts off every like you know how
like it's a very tropy thing to do for
like musicians to be like say some kind
of like thing Taylor Swift does it in a
way which is just like no disrespect but
it's just so incredibly corny where like
you know she would have like you know
one of her biggest songs is like you now
made an enemy of every Swifty out there
it's fine I didn't I didn't give a [__]
but like you know uh like you know the
song uh
like you trouble
you clip that's been going around Tik
Tok of the way that she introduces that
song and and there's so many paries of
it just being like you know haven't you
ever like been in a situation where
you've met a guy at a party and you just
knew that he was trouble and then the
song starts and it's just like bro come
on like can you can you do it in a way
that's like a little bit more
interesting please like yeah learn from
Lady Gaga man like do something
interesting with it I think it's it's
almost Terri terrifying to put so much
Fame on one person yeah I can't imagine
I mean that's what she kind of talked
about in her interview which was um yeah
it's not her fault I mean no it's not
her fault at all it's
terrifying what I found funny was you
know she was talking about the whole
thing that started with all the beef
that she had with Kanye I'm really happy
for you I'm let you finish but Beyonce
had one of the best videos of all
time like ruin career how it nearly
ruined her career and then she ended it
on what happened now and then she ended
it on but it's okay trash always takes
itself out or something along those
lines and I was just like I'm not a I'm
not a swiftly I'm not a tayor fan
[__] holy [__] Taylor you did not
need to go that hard how long do you
think she was like cooking that line she
was holding on to that line she's like
Kan is already dead I'm a win person of
the year I'm I'm AIT I'm holding on to
this I wish it was I wish that was I
wish it was true though I wish it was
true that trash took itself people trash
people do not take themselves out no TR
persist some of the most persistent
people in fact are trash yeah um that's
just how it goes Kanye still has a fan
base even after all the [__] he said
yeah man like insane thing coping on him
people always on cop but he made
graduation it's favorite M I just it
sucks cuz it's like man I I don't even
want to [__] talk about him because
I'm like this guy's piece of [__] let's
just let let's just let his him his name
become irrelevant but some people always
want to wait give weight to it cuz it's
like watching a [__] car crash yeah
well at this point it's more like
reality TV that's what it feels like
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly I mean a lot
of people do the same with YouTuber
drama as well which has also been spicy
this year as well they just don't see
them as real people in a sense right
like they just see it as like a show I
mean if you make a [__] apology video
with the ukulele do you deserve to be
seen as a real functioning I think that
was genius I think it was
genius I completely forgot about I'm
just saying that because everyone
remembers the apology nobody remembers
the apology everyone remembers the
ukulele it's genius what a what a MISD
in a sense that was
goed yes the drama itself was the Talk
of the Town for the week but now all I
ever think about is that funny ukulele
bit she did and yes there's drama
involved there but I think that most
people just remember it for the [__]
song yeah being absolutely horrible
[Music]
it was it was it was it was iconic we're
never going to top that as a human
civilization and apology it's
genius I don't know man give YouTubers
time to cook and I think we're going to
I think we're going to find something
new we'll find creative ways I mean
someone needs to write a book like a
textbook apology like how to how to
handle these kind of situations I'm
going to rush how to make an apology
video by kah no is that isn't that just
called PR which some YouTubers
definitely need in their lives yeah
toally is yeah PR's tough cuz every
everyone has an opinion and no one's
right A lot of the time mhm sometimes
all you can do is be wrong it's just
being less wrong well it's also in those
kinds of situations right like I feel no
matter how powerful of a PR team you
have it's just it's there's never a
winning situation like it's always a
lose lose mhm you know so it's just like
I don't know man just don't [__] up
hopefully hopefully well all right
Gamers enough about the Swift nonsense
what are you doing next year what's
what's on the agenda what do you think
what do you want to change next year
what do you want to do what's the big
thing what's the big are you talking
about New Year's resolution what's your
yeah what's New Year's goals I guess
more than a resolution I want to this
year I I raised 900 900 $950,000 for
charity I want I wanted to raise a
million this year while while I didn't
make my goal so I'm going to do it next
year still a [__] load of money bro I'm
going to do it next year easy I want to
play more genj next
year my goal for next
year my goal for next year is to start
and finish the trail series before Gone
why can't you guys have good goals
that's a great goal [__] terrible why
do you get ripped Joey I do I I don't
want to get ripped get ripped no I'm
good man give up Trails no Trails I'm
happy with how I look I do have a goal
next year but it is a secret and I don't
want to say it publicly yet because I
know happens when you talk about
projects
that actual goals I don't want to spoil
yeah because as soon as you say it want
Big Balls next year I'm getting a third
testicle I'm gonna juice them up
I'm massage them every
day I'm going do ball stretching
techniques my skirt will be down on my
knees bro what's okay give me a
superficial reward just a little thing
okay cuz you know I think sometimes it's
too easy to get lost in big
accomplishments right we all do this and
we're all guilty it and it's something
that I think is not helpful what I think
is more helpful is little things that
you want to change next year what is
something small in your life that you
want to improve on next year that is
just a small Improvement on your daily
life that you think will have better
ramifications on your life I want to
spend more time with friends and family
yeah that's pretty much the change that
I've enacted uh that's why I'm not doing
many convention experi uh like you know
we've talked about this we've doing less
traveling purely for work and that gives
me more time to travel for the stuff
that I value you know yeah I want to I
want to cherish more of like my private
life I think like just kind of you know
spend more time with obviously Ari but
also friends family you know meet new
people go travel you know just stuff
that isn't necessarily in front of
camera I guess and like you know cuz
like I feel like I've missed a lot of
that being a YouTuber you know yeah yeah
fair enough yeah same thing honestly I
feel like I haven't appreciated time uh
with with uh close ones as much trying
to balance that time but it's always
tough bouncing time is always tough for
sure and I think I think I got to that
point where I want to focus more on
exciting like you know generic kind of
like YouTuber things in my career I just
want to focus more on like exciting
projects uh that I have you know put a
lot of work and love into creatively
challenge yourself I'm not going to say
now uh just because I as soon as I say
it expectations are going to come and
I'm not going to want to work cook let
the man cook yeah yeah uh but that's as
vague as I am willing to be about some
of the [__] that I've been working on